πτεκα έχω σκεφτί αλλάξουμε σθελίδα γυροπάντώνα δρηση πριν α πω οσιδύο χρόνια περίπουν ποιο ήταν
τώραμα τότε όταν ξεκινούσε το γυροπάντωτώραμα τότε ήταν να δώσουμε στις γυναίκες και στις οικογένειες
του στις σωστή πληροφόρηση ξέρεται όταν είχα διαγνωστεί εγώ για πρώτη φορά το χιλια νιακόσι
νένητα έξι ίσως οι μουσυνδοποιημένοι είχα χασι και τη μητέραμου αποκαρκίνο του μαστού απ ότε
κάθεωρητικά ήξερα πολύ περισσότερα και πάλι βρέθηκαν σε αυτό που όνομάζω εγώ τον κόσμο της
αβεαιότητας που δεν υπήρχαν οι πληροφορίες που θα ήθελανα έχω που δεν υπήρχαν υπηρεσίες ισθάνομουν
ότι πρέπει να υπάρχουν και σκέφτηκα τότε μαζί με άλλες φίλες κι ότι δεν ήταν
ιστέλα τη πρωτοπουλία της θέλες αν εμείς οι οποίες έχουμε περάσει και κάποιες εμπιρίες έχουμε
και μια αλφαεπίπεδο μόρφωσης βρισκούμαστε σε αυτή την αβεται βεβαιότιτα και το χάως η υπόληπης
γυναίκες και οι αυτό προχωρήσουμε με την ίδρηση της γυρόπατονα κύπρου και αυτό ήταν τώραμα
ένα όραμα που δεν τελειώνει ποτέ πάντα υπάρχουν περισσότερα που μπορούμε να κάνουμε αλλά για
μένα προσωπικά η ορόπατονα κύπρου είναι μέρος στις ζωήςμου είναι είναι οικογένεια μου και είναι
έναν κομμάτι με το οποίο πάντα είμαι συνδεδεμένοι και θα συνεχίσω να είμαι συνδεδεμένοι αυτά
τα πωη δύο χρόνια πο υπάρχει ροπαντώνα υπάρχουν στιγμές που συντροφεύουν της τέλνα κυριακίδονα θέρνο
κάθε μέρα ο κάθε καθέ τηλεφώνημα που έχω και συνέχεισα εδώ πειπαίεται χρόνια που απουσιάζω
να με παίρνουν τηλέφωνο από γυναίκες από οικογένειες